elle est embarquée à bord de ce navire
c'est le navire du capitaine jack le
borgne un navire oui mais monté sur
quatre roues et que l'on a plutôt
l'habitude de voir dans les campings
pour trouver le trésor de jack le borgne
l'immersion se fait dans cette caravane
ils n'apprennent plus de 7 mètres de
loups en quoi j'ai tout à l'heure durant
45 minutes les énigmes s'enchaînent pour
cette famille et même si c'est un peu
exigu tous se prennent vite au jeu et en
oublient que leur bateau n'en est pas un
cet escalier mobile a vu le jour l'année
dernière et c'est julien le gérant qui a
tout fait dans une caravane des années
2000 il a imaginé les décors mais aussi
créer les énigmes effectivement c'est un
format un petit peu insolite
finalement c'est comme une petite salle
de théâtre est aussi ça permet d'aller
partout ça veut dire que même dans des
petites villes en campagne eh ben je
peux amener cette activité là il a fait
redécouvrir
c'était vraiment l'idée de rendre
l'activité accessible à tous les jours
une demi heure a suffi à cette famille
pour trouver le trésor dont nous ne
révélerons bien sûr pas l'emplacement
afin de garder le mystère entier
nous sortons vainqueurs l'impression que
la caravane est quand même relativement
grande avec ses succession de pièces
comme ça donc pas arrivé jusqu'au
jusqu'au coffre même à s'enfermer dans
le
dans la petite cage du kof là pour
trouver des petites énigmes et non mais
c'est très très très bien avec les
bruits la caravelle mobylette à semoy
dans le loiret jusqu'au 19 juillet elle
partira ensuite jeté l'ancré au bord de
la mer parfait